we got the Grammy boy here and I want to
hear all about it now it's Monday
everybody okay I'm feeling I'm wearing a
collared shirt now you don't why do that
culture my sneakers are probably $400
they're common projects guilt-free I'm
wearing Banana Republic stretchy jeans
because you know how I'm working you
know I'm working with when it comes to
my upper thighs and my ass buster I'm
still training hard you're busting out
fashion I'm busting out fashion why are
you closed shirt though what's that
what's that probably get hom you know
sometimes that just I just want to I
want to keep it real true and straight
don't say real though but I want to keep
it real true and straight right I want
to keep things tight to the bone now
this is also stretching material from
theory it hugs my waist I'm not worried
about that a lot of 51 year olds working
a little excess weight I think we know
what I'm working with
you working with a I'm working with a
six-pack they're not really an emphatic
manner and still a piece and get in
diamond-hard under the right hands
crooked teeth I had so I had to take my
mold they looked at me like oh you need
to start all over again maybe this time
I'm going to do it no that's not don't
pushing real braces on me 30 you know
theory is what I was wearing last night
well I gotta say I liked what you were
wearing you thought I'd go crazy on you
I'm not mad at a suede jacket and a
black turtleneck on the turtleneck you
know your smile can you not smile that
I'm so happy to be I know but you look a
little bit like an imbecile well no you
didn't see the one I posted the one I
posted with serious face you know people
have coaches for the red carpet you
don't need that no and if you get a coat
oh no I'll have to end a French no I do
a bunch of different faces just yeah
pick your poison
what the [__] James phone's ringing that
mine yeah you know to my defense I'm
stretch
fresh off the plane you haven't seen JFK
you haven't slept are you now welcome
our time oh yeah an hour yeah I got an
hour good hour and I was like you know
I'm just gonna sleep on the plane cuz we
wrapped so late I was like yo gonna
sleep done make sense um be so tired
I think the alarm gotta get home to do
find the kid sure
so get on the red-eye and I was you
gotta sleep I fall asleep out hard
you're that hard
I fall asleep Hardy he dreams oh yeah
yeah I wake up to old fat fat fingers
next to me on his lap
yes yeah add peanuts and go watch that's
so fun oh my god you can do nothing I'm
in Columbus Ohio great shows and a giant
gentleman plays basketball
by the way the Goldbergs there I get
recognized right I'm Bryan Callen they
cool it and it's and it's been four
years taking four years but you know
people and so and and what's funny is
that when you're in Columbus Ohio and
you've not been around actors and stuff
and you look at somebody who's on TV you
assume that their way wellthey ER and
way more famous then they are so this
guy really nice guy it's just a giant
guy you know we're talking and he said
he I play basketball at this college
here and I said Ohio State he said no
this other era college that okay and he
goes so do you usually fly commercially
or I mean or is it usually private you
have no idea I go brother I am NOT close
to a private plane I mean Kanye West
plays I mean commercial next to me this
was fun because I was sleeping and the
gentleman next to me who had been
missing no meals no meals through his
life very sweet man but was was farting
and just how I rude is that it was you
happy a war
you have to filter that through that big
old smells you guys it's the worst word
and put my my I was trying Smith sniff
my knee I was making it I will literally
pick it I will if so in farts on a plane
I will grab Mike up and smell the cup
just you know I go like this I cover my
face is the worst filter with your party
in that [__] tube like a K&N air
filter you can put your mask over you
know I came in yeah [__] you don't look
gain in this don't say KN because you
need prettiest I know Canada is what the
case the kit what can in where's it
going the car like what the KNN on the
on the turbo filter on the a vac valve
all right whatever man you don't know I
had a good time the long time in New
York by the way and you're not a big New
York fan for 83 days you know it's just
a lot it's a hustle you the weather was
actually pretty good little chilly
little chilly have octopus delivered
from Tavern our Taverna sick ladies my
favorite restaurant right on my first
street don't know don't know I'll tell
you I'll tell you to step their game up
in New York
uber drivers or not uber drivers right
there all right yeah no post mates they
get lost like it says Oh twelve minutes
to delivery and then an hour later and
they get the guy would come back bro I'm
up thirty fourth and seventh I'm like
I'm not I does not matter you might as
well speak in [__] Arabic I go Street
to me nothing to me yeah I don't know
the map is so confusing post mates New
York got stuff to game up but so I'll
and and then Friday I'll shooting all
day New Jersey can't say for what for
yet don't know but it's a shy little
mouth project come when I'll be land out
soon so I did have the best beats of my
life in New Jersey and you know what
they tell me you sent me know what they
tell me it's the water I know what you
said they go it's the water somebody
wants to Z Y dou Y on it got it Jersey
wanted beam is normally but because
Roseanne blur waters that she better
than bottled water you know that yeah
yeah Denver water's great however is
natural far yeah I've never heard Jersey
having great water of I and I lived
there and I'm from New York I'll say
this though Jersey gets a bad rap man
they get a bad rap because the Jersey
Shore MTV it's a great pilot there's a
lot it was amazing I was down the Jersey
Shore to the shore side great people
it's great place less crowded spent a
lot of time down there and less prouder
yeah it's good food that when I when I
was in Jersey sure I was with all my
boys Jimmy Burke in the end that and the
team guys fist pump and flood we did a
lot of that we were young men and I had
been in LA for a year of straight and
girls were talking to us I when I went I
went what's the agenda what do they do
they recognize somebody like I couldn't
understand that they were just being
normal human beings having a talk and
they didn't want something that's how
jaded I was it was super nice great
people well it's people have roots there
and and you know Jersey has believe it
or not you know you think of the
Turnpike but Jersey like so the joke was
always like you're from Jersey what exit
because it's the Jersey Turnpike yeah
Jersey has really big rural areas and
they say a huge population of wild
horses in Jersey but also most athletes
and celebrities a lot of them live in
Jersey because of
house is the land that you don't deal
with the chaos yeah which I always found
that weird like the Jets the Giants the
Matt's love the Yankees all live in
Jersey less lives in Jersey like why
they do that some nasty over there
that's my back yeah because when I've
been there remember the only time I've
been that cro cop in new war what Newark
Newark Newark Newark yeah oh that's I
know I meant to ask you yeah that's in
people in New York and basically
everyone's gonna roll their eyes at this
a Guinea how would you describe a Guinea
what's the definition of again my Guinea
it was always sort of a derogatory term
for an Italian so you so like Nina gay
not being full-blood telling I should
not call you on a Guinea um is it
frowned upon you know it's a Guinea T
like so when I have a tank top on you
know I wear those it's called a Guinea T
oh we call the wife beater on yeah but
again what writer and wife beater and
Guinea T are both good traditionally on
descending traditionally you were the
guy you were the kind of blue-collar
what guy in New York who's like getting
a bargain awesome that make me a goddamn
sandwich and you give her a whack yeah
this was you know if you gave me a lot
of money and nothing to strive for I'm
gonna get myself in trouble
I'll be one of those I mean those rich
kids in Beverly Hills yeah addicted to
percocet yeah I need a weird staff I
need bills and I need to be worried I
need to be stressed I got my I need I
need I don't need I don't need ya know
for me I need something I'm reaching for
so I need a little feeling of queer
dissatisfaction with myself like have
you ever seen bill gates excited no yeah
well he's trying to build something so
for me it's kind of like yeah built like
I'm working so hard at this one hour I
want to shoot because I think it's the
best thing I've ever done that's really
important to me not to win a Grammy you
know but to just I want it I want it
surprised myself I want to put it out
there you can win a Grammy now in comedy
I know I saw that
I love jebel oh my god someone's
represent for common like it's pretty
[__] cool man
you got Jerry Seinfeld there yet Kevin
Hart Dave Chappelle and Jim Gaffigan
yeah Jim Gaffigan who was hilarious and
opening hilarious hilarious yeah so he
gets out Jim Gaffigan
yeah I don't know who I am here either
and he was kind of funny I'm up for
award he is I'm I guess I was excited
about it you know something's up though
because I helped Dave Chappelle write
his acceptance speech he doesn't come on
we all know Dave Chappelle team win it's
hilarious awfully obviously Dave won but
they deem an ear Best Rock Album of the
year they put comedy over that you know
Dave Chappelle announced best rap album
in the year best rap song of the year
and it also opened up in the debut with
Kendrick Lamar so Kendrick is powerful
so Kendrick would do a performance then
Dave Chappelle would say something was
like spoken word then Kendrick would go
don'tcha bail well I'm glad you
mentioned Kendrick Lamar because ol 51
over here of course doesn't know [__]
about him and then I did a little
investigation don't you remember when we
recycle white arrows I drank there's a
small black Joe and Brian goes who's
that girl that's Kendrick Lamar you
who's that what that is the best hip hop
artist on place he's a real [__]
artist though cuz like I I always have a
judgment on this cuz I'm older and he's
like a rapper he's you know he's he's a
kid comes from a different culture
that's all and I listened to those words
man I mean what a [__] artist he is
in 51 and the reason I did is another
guy I know who's 50 my buddy Solomon he
made fortune and everything but he's
like my age and stuff and he was talking
about
Kendrick Lamar cuz he held Kendrick with
his clothing business way back in the
day mmm-hmm and he said you got to
listen to his lyrics and then his wife
said the same he's amazing and I'm like
get da [__] Compton this is the first
time I was fragile with tec-9 he did
which is you know and then I said all
the other [__] I was like I'm gonna go
down house last night I bet he did and
you know when I tell who stole the whole
night was Bruno Mars really Bruno Mars
he's great
destroyed it I mean he literally swept
it every category he won and then he's a
tiny guy so goddamn talented we had his
producers on our show the ones who
helped read all the stuff and produce
all of it I said is it true that and I
said tell me cuz I said I full-heartedly
believe this but you guys have you know
you work with the guy every goddamn day
I said he's the most talented man in
that arena and they went in the planet
he's dumb and they were you named an
artist these Oliveira yes
were they work with everyone Kesha I
mean yeah Hillary I'm everybody sure and
I see the most talented man that
building and they all they were having a
good time I'll get dead serious and
almost at the same time when he's most
out the man in the world on that arena
in the world what what did did you
dissect that what did you did you get
down to why now we'd have time we had
for like a minute yes cuz he just knows
music so well he's just so talented he's
so talented like Minh his acceptance
speech when he was 12 or 15 he did a
concert he was headlining when he was 15
for a thousand people yeah okay so it's
such a language for him he's been doing
it's a savant
he's also been like the Michael Jackson
out of it yeah he does everything dance
you know I seen him is insane yeah he's
amazing insane he's so goddamned you
know when I watch the I watched some of
the current Graham they're boring yeah
they were but goddamnit those people are
talented you see Charles again you know
Donald Glover with a little kid so
there's a new line can come out and the
kid who plays Simba bring that up chin
this kid comes out it gave me chills I
how about I went oh but how about how
about for a second Miley Cyrus I know
can she get a little like like I love
how people go bad on her fur without
she's dressed and all that [__]
I mean what a badass play that kid play
that kid singing like I was ridiculous
wait T see this little cute thing so
he's the new like King Simba obviously
you know Donald Glover childish gambino
I've seen Lion King on Broadway and I
don't know they're making the
straight-up movie huh and he's the
little one named Jay just stepped into
the building ladies and job off see
typing Grammys chin man let's see if
this that might be it he's so good he
won last night I feel like that's an
adult Oh Brendon wait
Grammy Awards along with a very special
guest along with many other talented
artists childish gambino perform tonight
his name is childish can't be all his
name's Donald Glover that's his rap name
which is getting rid of does that dog
over who all is he from Atlanta yes oh
he's up oh god mommy naka wrote and
directed oh my god what you talking
about
oh that writes directs and ktl oni sings
his ass up I gotta hear this I think he
wanted one or two Grammys here when the
big awards but he won my favorite
perform for the night well he's really
wait for you watch this chin I saw you
know music Joe how good is he that kid
is ridiculous how good those friggin
everything he does super talented man
acting writing directing singing if you
can sing like this you can act because
singing is basically conveying emotion
and knowing what you're saying
he's so gifted man he's also writing he
writes he raps sings rap he's amazing
rap she crazy wait for this little kid
to come out I got to start singing [__]
yeah you wait I get you an all-white
suit
I know do it but my voice oh say what
the e panel is not crazy about his shoes
though
it like heavy crushed-velvet shoes with
all white suit he's like that old school
swagged up me yeah he is damn wait for
this little dude to hit this stream I
think he's 14 I'm not sure doesn't sound
like like a Michael Jackson why she
comes out strong
what a bad like a little Michael Jackson
huh how about the white girl the
tambourine in the back how can I not get
that just it's harder than you think bro
no it's not see what she's doing did no
no I'm not playing that well you know I
mean homie you're gonna play that too
brother
no I can do this I'm gonna keep time
though portal but yeah you don't have
time we call it keeping time in the
music business bro you got to keep time
well she could play those fun good how
he dances look at that [__]
you're talking about tight movement
right there brother you're talking about
tight easy though I'm not worried don't
say that either
listen to me right now see he's just
he's just keeping very he's in a
cylinder right now will they be able to
see this Chin's occupying his own he's
occupying his own cubic space right now
we're just swaying right now waste
player with the with the green suit
uh-huh all right well well alright is
what you want to say you want to say all
right because there it is there it is we
got some bass here
bass players are very specific oh it
says he's ten years old no no I read it
he's ten now you can't do that fast
fortune you won't be able to play this
whole thing for it
here he is what
there is East tan Brian what were you
doing at 10:00
[Music]
keep out of our caddy I love America I
love my country
we'll take it easy there huh
[Applause]
Jeannie chills we've got some prints in
him
[Applause]
it's and Brian you're 41 years old 51 oh
yeah 41 years old
yeah I got nothing brother good stand it
though man music like that that how
about that
are you sure Easton and that's training
to that kids a is 10 what multiple
websites these days he's 10 years old
and he drinks a lot of milk he's very
tall you can play a ball - he can ball
how insane what races how obscene is
that though that was my favorite
performance at night I believe it the
catch the one the catch was powerful
because she went through all that stuff
oh did she go through a lot of stuff is
that what it was I don't know sir she's
only very very emotional there and she
oh oh why because she was raped by her
manager and then he tied her into the
all this red tape so she couldn't sing
for two years and then find that comes
out she won in court and now she's on
her own she can finally sing again oh
boy so first came in oh sorry about that
everybody
I didn't even hook catch it was but she
looked very very you know she could sing
yes what did you say
would you know I know
and I'm not gonna hear and say that no
she she can shoot like kill you sir
Clarkson sister know what Brandon she
was so emotional check she has some pipe
she could it you're so emotional she
couldn't almost get it out that's tough
that's tough it's tough I saw your girl
because this time you know he gave me
more stuff to do which is a good sign
saws in the pre-show and post-show but
the pre-show I'm there you know strip
red carpet when everyone's coming in and
Lady Gaga in death I felt bad can I ask
what cash you what she was wearing
she was wearing like she was straight
off the set of death becomes her okay
and we've been all wet black but big you
don't give her like it was cool can you
finish this yet are here like the the
mother of the dragons which I approve
mother of dragons she was so serious
that has this thirty person entourage
behind there's a problem and someone one
that one of the people I was working
with kind of knows and go oh and goes
lady and she turned on goes
yeah she says she's serious Karen I do
matters when I said you look at her eyes
on it he was like oh she's so Chih oh so
much money when you come over I just
went oh oh I want to be like this you're
playing a character and you're lonely
you're playing a character right now
yeah that's a character that's not real
now I feel bad for now I feel like you
get they get so famous to go down these
rabbit holes and it's just like such a
lot I think also that you know it's a
reality it's also a little bit like some
people who the only time they're happy
is when they're in the Octagon or
performer yeah and I think that's the
case because you know I heard that she
just can't did you also want to connect
with somebody have a real relationship
and she's had a hard time with that her
last every straight did to die me yeah
but it didn't work out doesn't you know
know like I wonder what that subject I
didn't want to drink blood what mm-hmm
yeah yeah but she went by I was like God
ain't man I know and then there was
these guys who are up for a country
album of the year there's three of them
and I dug their outfit I forget who
they're I wish you could bring her up
chin the handsome note boys or sorry man
sorry did I I'm not doing anything okay
okay like I know it no but but they were
all dressed like in this cowboy outfits
and the three of them combined I can
[__] with yeah but I was roasting behind
their back and went know which they
should not separate they should combine
hands if you need to get a drink you
stay together because once you go off on
your own you guys look [__] weird
like super weird I'm talking flamboyant
cowboy big boys too big boys big boys
big boys as in they haven't no they just
thought like that was huge yeah did Gaga
performed yeah I thought yeah I thought
she had an off night yeah that's fair so
oh did you see the girl in des besito
did you see the girl who's with them and
death mesito
no I sure the top three why I've ever
seen Wyatt top three sir I don't know
live with a 34 years K I don't know
where they found her care for Mars today
did they there she is
yes girl yeah
mom there's an issue when you see her
dance and her face was despot Seto I
already like these he everyone I was
like I like those too and I'll see I
have to filter myself we'll bill on me
blase kook who's the man she can dance
yeah I'd like to see her dance a little
bit
Oh what wait till you see it a coyote
Farah well yeah there's seat there are
dancers and then there's everybody else
then there are Latin dancers Oh
have you ever seen the Latin Grammy
Award I see that so much sexier than
ours there's so much 100 percent even
the back tens get a hundred percent -
you know that you've heard the song
right Oh have you heard this song no but
I'm liking it you know her decibel seat
there Oh Lord this horrible video well
that'll make you that'll not force you
to compromise everything you could lose
your house you all that make you risk
everything yeah it was loose I'll risk
everything right everything right Avenue
house her risky what do you mean my kids
I lost them I will figure it out I'm so
mad I'm so mad but oh boy yeah that'll
kill you that'll destroy a man that'll
bring you right to your knees I was
watching on satellite on your back house
like this uh-huh
you bite your own hand you bite your own
hand on national TV when you see that
and that's a big problem she the most
gorgeous oh she can move yep
yeah you know by the way that person
exists perfection exists somewhere right
Sophia might be that physically yes that
around she's to have a conversation with
I don't make sure well read I wouldn't
care if she was mute but that doesn't
mean either Yeah right I only speak
Spanish we'll figure it out yeah I'll
learn to vanish very quickly you know I
love the language I love the language I
love her yeah yeah no no and I want to
say something I love her too don't ever
talk to me about her again because she's
mine just shut your mouth you don't even
know the shut your mouth
or you and I will be in a fisticuffs
light I do believe you'd beat me however
you're sitting with her and you're still
a little weak in the tummy and I'll sock
in your [__] stopping her you do it
yeah I shall fight dirty
Sara Solomon yes seriously
Oh what she was in let her do she was in
that um she was in that movie battle of
the sexes have you seen
no we're it's about a Billy Joe with
Billy Joe King right Billy Joel King Oh
Billy Billy Billy Jean King and in fact
when I was in New York she was sitting
with Emma Stone at a restaurant one of
my favorite dining we need to [__] uh
here ago okay and I said to her hey how
are you I'm a big fan because she was
such a groundbreaker Mooji he was the
openly gay tennis player and not true
she wasn't openly she was not openly gay
talk really yeah she got but she was she
took a lot of heat anywhere for that
it's like kinda Martina Navratilova as
well both yet but they do it after the
career she's not that groundbreaking
like if she did it wall she's playing
she was kind of a ground breaking
athlete for a lot of reasons right after
the fact
yeah after she did all her work yeah I
learned just watch the doc I'm a stoma
that's a good movie man see girls great
in it yeah he was a demon putana fire
did you did you watch I'm excited did
you watch the real match though yeah
yeah really yeah it's crazy
he's great and and they would never do
that today like Serena Williams versus
uh 55 while he was ha he was making he
was trash-talking
I'm not win motor and stuff well he's a
promoter yeah you didn't really believe
all that I use just a hustler yeah he oh
he was also a very good tennis player
and I don't think she knew how he was
world champion oh he was yeah world
champion well he was a wasn't he a d1
player was he a professional professiona
okay yeah he won the he won the the open
like you the US Open oh my god retired
yeah he's 55 and he's a compulsive
gambler and but he was a real nice guy
and he came to her and was like we can
make a lot of money we try and get money
and get equal playing field I'll play
the bad guy you do this oh he's a
hustler oh I didn't know that it was it
was I'm sorry I don't know if she liked
him okay so so so this was all an act
yes she shouldn't she goes he's he's a
fool he's a hustler she goes I'm not mad
at him she hated the guy who ran all of
tennis because he wanted to bet he
banned all the women from tennis he want
to pay him less oh that's why she was
gonna do this and then they were gonna
try and make that that man who's the
head of the whatever the the men's
tennis association MTA whatever it is he
was gonna try and ban all women if she
was gonna play this and then he was also
gonna try to be the competative for that
super match yeah
and she goes well I won't play this is
the day before she was I won't play if
he's the commentator was this the first
time that was was Billie Jean King a
were like a Grand Slam champion at the
time yes she's number one in the world
Wow
so he put so hold on he played the
number two girl who was from Australia
and he beat the [__] out of her first
cuz I'm Billie Jean King turned it down
so he went to the number two girl who's
Australian got she B can you bring up
some of match for the hell of it
yeah so that Australian girl who's
ranked number two actually beat Billie
Jean King and then so he went to her and
because Billie Jean King won't even
entertain it but then when she realized
like what how big profound would be and
she couldn't even try to beat him she
beat the [__] out of him but he won
ultimately didn't he know Billie Jean
King took over and beat the [__]
oh I did not know that he got exhausted
she had him running all over the court
here she is look at this oh so she ended
up beating the [__] yeah she beat him
bad Oh is he okay
I thought like rats and [__] no she beat
him how arias she beat him and then you
know I feel bad for her husband man cuz
obviously she's gay he had the sugar
daddy shirt on he played and he he
wasn't taking that serious and sweating
his ass off like you got a ditch to go
like to pay me 20k something create like
nineteen million people watch this by
the way brother we got a different their
strokes were back then so different now
it's such a power game such if I wonder
how like the Serena Williams or Venus
Williams would do against that I like
this top tank I know top ten males did
get destroyed they get discriminate
destroyed she would get destroyed and by
her own admission they'll tell you that
their men are too but a 55 or 55 year
old she would destroy oh yeah and this
is like Pete Sampras oh [__] yeah though
she'd probably still be bit you know 55
is old that's that's that's all you he
had some problems yeah she had a brother
on her play that was a game plan she I'm
just hustling all even though the top
hundred guys I mean Martina after all's
said she can't
never they just hit too hard you know if
you're if you're in the top hundred has
a tennis player
forget top ten if you're in a top
hundred it's it's a huge accomplishment
what Bobby Riggs won though he was
hilarious you know you'd he'd play like
the pros that the at the course he would
hold dogs and they put chairs and I girl
what do you guys want to bet some guy
bet in the Royals Royce he'd beat the
[__] out of him
music alright that's so great he's he's
so good he's a real one
I see if you got his Wikipedia see what
he won why isn't there more talk about
Billie Jean King with everything going
on I thought Bobby Riggs won the match
but he didn't no he did not
yeah you actually like faded Hart again
you use a professional career he won the
US Championship in the wimba like ah
yeah in 1910 won the ground yeah he won
the Grand Slam in 1939 holy [__] old
school that doesn't make sense wait and
then into a 60s and 70s he still won so
I won the US proud then he won the US
Championships and then yeah he won well
bulton so I mean legit tennis player huh
yeah I don't think people realize how
good of tests play with and then he
would do it as a side house to make
money we always talk about that when you
got a pro like that they that the
difference is also not just physical
professional players who have won huge
events like that are gamers they can
they can find a way to win they'll [__]
with you they mess with your head they
do all kinds of stuff right yeah I mean
they'll do they can get into your they
can get climb into your kitchen yeah
drive a window open somewhere in your
house and they're climbing in they're
gonna [__] he chose that Margaret Court
and beat the [__] out of her and that's
that's why Burke would do this to me
Jimmy Burke all he's played ball his
whole life and by no means a
professional he played every sport he
loves he loves the game and he's always
been an amateur and he loves to play and
everything and I've watched Jimmy beat
really good guys in the court cuz he
gets in your head and with me where I
would work really hard at my tennis
whatever he would look at me and he'd
just [__] with me he'd go like this he'd
go he'd do little things that I just
didn't know what he was doing he'd go
dude you know I'm gonna climb into your
kitchen right are you all the windows
shut you don't have a window open here
you don't have a little window open
because I feel like there's a window
then I'm gonna climb through and just
that I go fight you're not getting in my
head dude he goes no no but just close
all your windows before we start now if
you're playing an actual Bravo
right okay here's the other thing my
fighter buddy my everybody like
illustrate good he knew my backhand
sucked it wasn't good so he'd hit to my
back end and add right firstly hit the
back end he would stop his foot like he
was just little things like that like
hey you know are ya natural flow he's
got 1,000 ways to beat you one time
watch the fights this week I did most
ratings ever for Fox yeah I don't know
what to thinking man are they trying to
bomb this thing so I don't know you know
Amazon's out of the the TV deal it was
um pulled out which is a big deal I know
yeah that's not a big it's a big deal
why because there's no other players in
the game so there's no competition now
you only have one you have company right
now Fox and Fox all the power a few UFC
you make a certain nut to cover your
debt
yeah so that's why it's a big deal that
the roundhouse kick that the Taekwondo
roundhouse kick was very impressive from
Jacare
you talked about the head kick yes sir
yeah with his foot the top of his foot
yeah um I need to give my boy Cory sand
again a shout-out he's from Denver he
started at high altitude when I was
there and he's always Chris Jones like
beasts and kicked off the night when his
first fight I think he won that war -
yeah feather way it is what is that is
that 45 45 yeah yes render like oh I saw
that fight yeah he was great one of the
night yeah you watched on fight path no
I watched it on regular TV isn't bypass
no it wasn't because I was in I wanna
tell me I watched it on TV at in
Columbus so maybe that fight passing
come well I watched the whole thing I
watched a run all routes to the Brunson
fight on on the TV there maybe think I
don't know check it out B so the guy Oh
timeout cause Hanigan only fun fight
paths
okay not TV psycho I promise it so the
other ones run the other ones on Fox
worth them you watch the main card on
Fox which that's everyone yes Fox
yes yes but I wonder why they had it on
at Columbus maybe they brought made it
maybe they brought it on on the regular
broadcast or maybe you're lying no no
nobody confused
I watched maybe but you if you saw
remember if you saw remember Cory
because he was so excited after he won
like if you saw it then then I'm sure
they put in the prelims or the main card
yeah they probably just added it in
there
yeah what is Ronaldo who does Jacare
fight next
who does he fight here oh wait yeah yeah
I could see a Chris Weidman if he's
healthy or I could see the Kelvin
Gastelum
if from between the Luke and the the yo
Romero fight he won't fight the winner
of that why because he's already Robert
Witter could be back in time so that the
winner of that's gonna fight Robert
Whittaker you won't fight you'll romero
do we know out Whitaker's doing after
that staff got into his intestines
you should be alright once they get on
antibiotics he posted on Instagram
afterwards he'll be okay yeah I imagine
Chris Weidman or Kelvin Gastelum if
you're jock gray they should just go and
take George st. Pierre out of that
number four didn't why is George number
four shouldn't he be at least number one
cuz he vacated I might hold no because
if it was all you'd be has Joey vacated
the Bella yeah but how do you learn
number four no no I greased by that's
not carrot reading he's not beating
Jacques all right no no no he's not B's
not bananas guys they're just too big
yeah they're way too big
Kelvin Gastelum might be his best
matchup there cuz that he's similar in
size mm-hmm but don't they so Whitaker
and those guys are just they hit too
hard this is too big and he knows that
dude how about we call it DC steep a
happening actual super fight now I know
my station on that is that it goes the
distance and I'm gonna go with Cormier
I'm going with DC only because and it's
such a it's such an intriguing and
tricky fight and the only reason I'm
going with DC is because I think DC has
better cardio and I think that I think
he's a better wrestler obviously I don't
think that steep a size in the wrestling
is going to make that much of a
difference to Daniel because also build
power strike
why's I I feel like Daniel has spent
enough time back in the day sparring
with guys like Cain back in the day yeah
I mean Kane hasn't probably been
training for yeah it's such a class I've
never seen listen you know this better
than I do but I've never seen DC
actually get rekt wreck rocked except
for one executive job by punches except
for n it's more kick so when he dips and
he gets if you get caught with that shin
the way he did with John Jones that's
what rocks him but he seems to be so
he's just good at avoiding it yeah so do
you pay his heart he's fought thought he
does huh
maybe not Anthony Johnson Anthony
Johnson hits a big boy yeah it's a tough
fight this is the bait that's why it's a
legit super if he doesn't do a lot of
cardio
I'm star being trouble is gonna be in
trouble man you can't beYOU know if he
comes in though he came in Francis Witt
granted he was tired from beating the
[__] out of Francis that's gonna take
your cardio but with DC I got caught -
growling yeah but with DC if he's calm
say pressuring and ten take its toll on
you if he's if DC's is able to lend
those takedowns early on it goes the
third fourth round DC you finish you off
that's right it's a I'm not picking DC I
don't know I'm not making bets or
breakdowns yet I don't know who to pick
this is why this is a legit super fight
because it can go either way us and
they're both champions this is of the
first like legit superb is being not a
super fun yeah and-and-and-and both
fights that by me for both guys it seals
their legacy as like just see this is a
wild side being super fight I think both
guys win or lose it their legacy sealed
no one has any I agree I mean I agree
FDC goes up are you lost everybody but
you lost it but if steep a defends his
title and beats DC I'm going then then
you have a very strong argument for why
you know you could say things like
greatest heavyweight of all time
even though I think Kane beats I believe
Kane in his prime which is doesn't
matter it doesn't matter and so so and
if Daniel beats steep a Wow Wow how what
kind of mix-up is because if Daniel
beats T pay his losses John Jones always
loom over
because if Tanner beats eBay then
everyone's just gonna go will judge you
Biff DC beats the eBay what do you think
John Jones would do do
so anything DC does it's like okay but
what would John Jones do - well Jojo
he beats if DC beats steep a he rides
off in the sunset I would then like to
see John Jones come back with one
warm-up fight and then fights deeper so
Steve a has to fight DC then John Jones
even if he doesn't have the belt
well student you do have steep a verse
John for the intern notice yes sir so
what happens is DC wins he vague about
it goes back to steep a now steep a
stance no it does go back to steep it
doesn't beat him no steep it would have
to fight soon for the belt really okay
okay okay so so he'd fight somebody for
the [__] can't beat him like my bad who
would be who would that be
who's next in line for Cain would need a
warm up than probably cane or veux doom
Harvard him he's already done work with
ver doom yeah but and Cain has its cage
around his spine so I don't know what
happened slim pickins for yeah they're
assumed that steep a wins that but
either way either way I think you're
gonna see DC steep a and I think you're
gonna see and I think it's gonna be a
war and I think it's gonna go to the
distance and then I think you're gonna
see ultimately steep a and our boy
John John Jones then what kind of let
you see is that for steep if you were to
lose this DC and John Jones that's the
risk of being an MMA fighter at that
level every there are no easy fights
well especially if you're a champ yeah
and they want to make super fights right
now yeah from what I hear that July card
they're trying to do it because you know
they're TV right so we're trying to show
they can still flex on people they're
due gonna do cyborg I'm Anna Nunez TJ
Mighty Mouse Steve Betis I can't [__]
wait but by the way I think steep Bay
has done all this you got to take this
into account too he's done all this
incredible work with a camp PDP 301 well
then that's very very legit that's very
legit and also you know those food was
undefeated for 10 years old old I get
that but he had all the resources he can
to drugs well if you watch it current
and probably had some things going on
you think and and it was just different
time he was in as complete
IPE the games of all deep a is actually
facing tougher cop 100% it and and but
you also have to take in the month
what is steep based training camp it's
not very sophisticated it's guys in
Cleveland I mean all new brats at all
yes and no he does he does train with
you know read long ago he does applied
men all right the world yester all right
this guy's not full-time so does he go
to Long Island and trade down there are
yeah all right
because been going initially you're
talking about a full-time I agree it's
not from like a super camp all the time
firefighter probably has trouble finding
guys his ties to train with price to fly
a man or go there I mean there's a lot a
lot of factors that he's Pamela do it
drives UFC nuts you know I don't most of
you know drugs UFC nuts that he has
another full-time job they hate that I
view what can you imagine if Tom Brady
had another feels like a work that IQ
shut up and saved your life
steep a yeah gotta get kids that kids
have been taken care of what my dog dogs
been taken care steep a music just quiet
down breathe have you pitch day calm we
go guys picks me up pick me up oh my hey
my feet are dangling save me I say bro
right before we get out there and put me
down I like I like real burnable right
now let me just put me down a little
mouth to shade all about to give you a
little Cleveland mouth-to-mouth look a
he talks could he be any more macho
yeah yeah beat this part yeah I'm gonna
give me some mouth-to-mouth yeah he's
silly huh he's so intense I don't have a
baby yeah dude he's a woo girl but a ya
guy he's like being given of a woo girl
you know girls like wow he's like yeah
he's a ya guy yeah yeah he's that got
all the girls put my new kitchen in you
blue cause he had a blue collar I'm
putting my kitchen even be a [__] put
a kitchen in save a [__] and save you
from a burning building and [__] you up
he's impressive as hell actually yeah
yes I hope they make this crazy Bank
tube and you train with him for a long
time when he was starting out there was
nothing that you would probably suggest
would would would you back then you
wouldn't have thought he would make it
to this level would you
you never know I mean I know I'm not
surprised I think but to say work I
think is he's athletic you know this
chin scrape it not to be the best of all
time no when he walked in I didn't say
he's gonna be the best of all time right
now that's fair to say yeah
and we knew he's damn good yep damn good
I think it's got that weird intangible
we did about it and he's a good he's
boxing he stood on the edge of that
pocket and just figured him out would
you do this weekend chin saw you saw you
posted the new that you're in that new
skyscraper downtown singing and [__] by
yourself
yes I was just moving stuff in house the
acoustics in that bad boy it's pretty
good is it's actually too good though
why cuz if I want to record stuff in
there like music and stuff you don't
want that much reverb reverb and echo
should play you trying to make the
recording studio I want to make music
there for sure really are you trying to
drop in out up an LP I just like writing
so if I've made a song can we all do a
song that Jan can you write fighter in
the kid a song can we like what there's
a project I'll have chin write the the
main will go down and we'll record it
and do a video let's do a music video to
be so stupid
so down all right let's do write it chin
all right what do you been doing just
been moving into the new crib moving in
the crab and then visiting the folks
how's your mom she's getting so much
better so I'm Sam better way better
think good good good that's cool a
little update on my stomach and so I'm
that copying over three weeks now don't
touch it I tried it actually feel sick
so it's what the coffee company on hold
and then stomachs good it is all I'm all
gravy baby I'm back I love it I'm sure
I'm back on the road Wednesday I might
die from too many flying mouse bum yeah
you back as a once Dan what time
yeah look alright I got you brother I
know all about it
I'm back on the road DC improv Thursday
Friday Saturday I fly out this little
short flight Thursday no no I'll fly out
Thursday and yeah and then I got oh did
you go to Hamid rather than actually go
homage the shirt I got didn't it's
literally a [__] good throw on this
yes you could throw it still
from your homage yes I didn't I forgot
what is that sure it's the best shirts
in the world really
they're great like my teacher hats
t-shirts hoodies sweats
all Cleveland owned Cleveland made ah
they're like we told everyone Brian's
coming in we'll take care of him hottie
on that hold your ass sorry I'm a
podcast we go
shout out to Amish look at all this
stuff great [__] wait I think the guy
brought me something
I doubt it Brian it's all right yeah I
think they gated somebody for my
birthday I they gave me two shirts that
I have let me can use this good sir on
them they would've gave me just two
shirts they're really nice shirts anyway
anyways I've been up to MJ chillin
so I taking a picture with dogs on
Instagram whose dog is that that's your
dog scrappy 101 we look alike right well
scruffy crazy eyebrows maybe a little
bit of beard I shaved mine let's say you
look like MJ let's go with a goatee yes
sir can we take a restroom break real
quick yes [__] huh I got this [__] guys
so weird about [__] and also why is
it like a Taco Bell bathroom in the
[__] bathroom here it's when you go
in there there's always always at least
one or two men the worst [__]
al-qaeda that back there Mir dropping
bombs so bad and it smells awful no yep
that is the busiest adulation that
bathroom was busier than the trucks yeah
they called me on stage Thursday and
Stevie comes into the Stevie blue-ice
comes into the thing I go what the you
guys they're calling the music playing
right now I'm peeing I'm in the middle
you ever try to pee really fast oh my
god come on come on oh yeah I will let
the music play could you want to pinch
that off it burns and I tried to pinch
it off I couldn't I just let it go yeah
that's the worst all right let's take a
break Gina's drop a deuce they yearned
for some reason the urine splashes it's
always on the ground you know before we
jump current events y'all
[Music]
excuse me sir excuse me sir
you're 51 now that's my birthday you
guys I didn't make a big deal about it I
mean ever I do it's fine you performed
on your bday yeah it's so cool they all
and happy birthday they'll start what
are we gonna do for your birthday dinner
um yeah we do dinner we have time to do
it next week yeah let's do it next week
definitely have it dinner what are you
under Scapa yeah we always you always go
to Via Veneto
let's go mister set up a scopa yeah
we'll just go up up
should we go put something like that you
know you trying your fancy go to Malibu
they'll go ahead service [__] are you
I know you don't know who that the bills
20 pick if you have a lot of people you
like someone who were gonna bite you
Amanda me Joe yeah friends Grillo Frank
and Wendy Frank Wertheim Bri to Indiana
Rogan doobie Doo Rogan I don't know if
he's my go we got big group weird ladies
down you bite the load P was like that
Jojo behind Jack Horner no yeah who's
goes over there yeah we'll figure it out
we'll figure it out III gotta say I was
signed a really weird I had this like so
and my final show on Saturday everything
I'm doing is really gelling right and I
feel really good about I want to shoot
my special Y monster best I've ever seen
it's yeah thanks man I do I feel like
I'm better than I've ever been and I and
I really felt that Saturday while on
your face for whatever I do have a spot
on my face work that what is that what
where I don't know I got a little little
zit okay yeah it's a little no that's
definitely not a tumor if it doing yeah
you know what you're right about fifty
one exams face Tim no no yeah you know
you ever sit it
I think slammed I I said oh yeah yeah
now make sense my wife said I should be
worried about nothing that just a huge
bump showed up underneath your eye well
what I have to and I have to do
Goldbergs tomorrow so I have to wear
makeup and I don't know if they can
cover this great just right well we can
say though for your birthday and and in
my last show Saturday I just it's just
everything quite
and that show was the best that one of
the best I've ever done and they stood
up and they [__] stood up and I felt
like crying and I had to run off stage
and their emotion
I suck at emotion but not me I was so
overwhelmed by them and that that and I
was so I don't know I just I almost
started crying I had to run away - I
wish you would have cried heartless I
kind of almost did I went I went thank
you and I could feel it and then I ran
off it was really cool I you know me
I'll cry on the spot I don't give a [__]
up ground on TV yeah yeah yeah I don't
care I don't care it's good but I in
Boston they give me a standing ovation
and Brogan's then I was like definitely
a crime from Rogen he's got as good as
motion as Brian is I'm gonna yeah Romy's
cried in front of me actually when his
friend died Rogen started crying we were
at dinner a long time ago probably [__]
man this might be 15 years ago and this
guy he really loved died he was a he was
a crazy dude and he started to cry right
there we were together at Chaya were
they black to a Beverly Hills they were
black tears they were they were black
tears they were tar I actually had them
tested they were made from tar and so he
cried tar and blood from his eyes just
yeah yeah we got do a bday dinner though
for you you do something I want to do
that master yet that was your fifth year
so special you have but I do believe in
marking I I'm a big believer in
celebrating moments no you're not I
should what you're the worst and I love
it you tried telling me what what did I
do
oh no I'm not so full of [__] we're like
when I did the Wilbert you're like bro
you need to take this in realize what's
going on but when it's coming from you
it's like it's like it's like a
motivational coach you can't afford
their power bill tell me like how to pay
my bills to get my life together
you're like you need to you need to
relish this realize what you've done I'm
like right get out of here [__] yeah
[__] off
no but I do think that it's important to
like it's your peers in you uh you and I
both suck down we both so I get sat on
my birthday you know that you do yeah I
don't know what it is well I feel you
get sad or didn't make a big deal about
it like a little no I don't know I buy
gifts I don't know I don't like it
yeah unless you get the gifts I want I
don't
my friends to buy Micah's too expensive
I was in a courtyard marriott room on my
birthday
are you saying oh I missed a day yeah
but it's a nice hotel yeah at least
connected on it yeah I love it that's a
great gig come on sing the funny bones
were one of the best clubs period and
you know I agree it's the only one my
fit is so good because you can walk
around there's so much to do it's a huge
club the crowds are great I'm not just
saying I'm not going any time soon for
another year funnybone Columbus one of
my favorites yep
no question oh man I'm a - it's weird
I've never performed there I'm at The
Comedy Store I'm sorry the Comedy Works
downtown Denver's I says that's their
favorite class is another one that is as
good as the funny bone and again one of
the best clubs in the everyone special
they're like that Rosa embargo started
like right first of all they take your
cell phones first of all no one there
will have a cell phone
lovely just wait till you see how just
wait do you see what it does to the
audience this guy [__] who's a
big-time computer scientist entrepreneur
made a fortune and he said you know
we're spending a lot of time looking at
our second brain and he's calling
computers and phones our second right
it's fair and it's fair and he said we
better be careful because you spent
enough time looking at your second brain
you're gonna stop communicating with
your brain you're not gonna have a sense
of how your own brain works you're not
gonna have a sense of how you work and
you're gonna lose touch with the inner
machinations of your brain of your soul
of all they look at a concert you go to
country see phones like this I'm
watching it through another length right
you're not your dude you paid for a
ticket like Mel what's on TV they jeez
way better what you're doing so there
watch out a second length and to show
everyone look what I'm doing look what
I'm hearing listening - yeah it makes
zero sense zero sense man it makes zero
sense
and I thought like better away even when
I was on the e panel like in between
takes or before everyone's on the phone
do all this stuff I get my phone the
they give everyone's scheduled an
assistant so I get for my final don't
give it to me I want to be focused
I'll be dialed in I don't see what's
going on we're watching words everyone
else on the phone yeah I'm like I'm
Tony's hurting you guys don't know it
this is hurting guys you're not in the
moment now I'm thing about what's next
with this live in the moment you're
losing
himself but yeah I remember it's live
and there's a live crowd behind you so
you can and that's where the comic value
comes in when you're doing live
performances I can feel the energy off
them there it dialed into their phone
that's right I think it's a mistake I do
too
they're still very good the job I do too
and as soon as I go in commercial to go
yeah your brain is starting to live on
the outside of your body and I think and
you're staring at it all day and and and
you're not present you're not present
and you're not present within yourself
you're not present within your own mind
get the cancer yeah as much as cell
phones help I think I think you've gone
as far as E and go ops you do get
virtual reality and all that other stuff
but as far as what they're meant for as
far as you can go and now it's just
here's a video game here's my kids
they're video games it's like yeah and
here's another thing that's really scary
if you take Facebook Google Amazon and
this Facebook Google Amazon who's the
other big one anybody anybody help me
with this Facebook Google Twitter
Twitter um Facebook owns this game yeah
if you take those if you take those
those those they were looking at how
first of all first of all those big when
it's Amazon Facebook Google and there's
I don't think it's Twitter it might be
something else but anyway those
companies as huge they are they're
controlling all our information they're
all of the news yes and and and they
only employ about apparently like
500,000 people they don't employ that
many people because of the technology so
it's not like them you know create a job
no they don't mean you've got nine tech
billionaires that are that have more
money than 1.8 billion people in the
world yes and and more importantly they
are controlling the not only that this
is really [__] scary not only are
they controlling the way we get
information but they're also the
algorithms are disseminating information
specifically to you on top of where we
talked about this with Facebook Facebook
had an algorithm right and also they
noticed that there were a lot of people
that were putting in Jew and hater so
all of a sudden it created an algorithm
for Jew hater and it was sending
information that supported that to
people that however in a manner that is
a problem but when you say they're not
giving people jobs
I would argue they imply they employ
more people than anyone in the world
actually they don't they do you ready
yeah they do because we're employee of
them we we write business off that yeah
my brother runs a bigot music artist
runs the business out them if your mom
has a store she has to run it through
yep well yeah they all run it through
them and well it's on their platform
they don't give up personally they don't
hold on they don't give a percentage to
give them a platform to run a business
how many businesses are run through
Facebook Instagram Twitter all and all
this thing but really social media man
in this day and age they're employing
more people than anyone in the world
ever meant more before if you like it
that way yeah you to it there's there's
a there's a obviously the Internet has a
bright side but there is a dark side and
the dark side is this conglomeration of
power and I think they did something
about if you put those four companies
together they they are like the seventh
biggest economy in the world I mean it's
crazy I'm but here's the thing baby but
who's responsible okay are you just
gonna get your news off your cellphone
whose fault is that mine yeah it's on it
that's oh that's on the individual yeah
it's not Facebook's what I worry though
about that is that there used to be like
Stewie's there used to be a trusted
source of information right so you knew
that no matter what if you went to the
news that everybody agree there was a
consensus on that on those advantage it
no there's no national America people go
hold on I have my side of the argument
what are your sources no and then we
can't even agree on sources because you
can go and find your own story has been
so there there are all these issues that
are interesting that we're kind of
dealing with I would argue they employ
more than anyone in the history of
mankind well we're we're the biggest
thing that we're gonna have to contend
with this 47% of the jobs that we know
of today are gonna go away in the next
20 years and the question is how do we
what do we do if their dad I said that
you have to adapt that but that's that's
that's life
yeah that's with anything that's right
because with innovation companies
becomes destruction when you come over
the better way to do something you don't
need the old way don't be blockbuster
and and you're right and and as you guys
tired car don't you and I live in a
world we've always had to like as an
actor is it I've seen this business
changing how much this business
you Bennett oh my god I mean and and and
if you don't get with the times and
embrace social media something I
resisted for so long you're in deep
trouble you got to keep it all talking
about this with the Showtime guys
especially as a comic unless you're a
Seinfeld Kim Hart's bags in because he's
the best social media in the game but if
you're a Seinfeld if you're a Bill burr
type if you're a Joe Rogan type he's a
bad example but if you and you don't
have a podcast phone that is your direct
lifeline to your fans without you oh you
can do a radio tour this day and age
what do you do you put a billboard and
think that's gonna sell ticket disdain
age now you're competing with all that
stimulus that people are good social
media so if you don't have a podcast and
you're a performer and you're trying to
sell something or take it yeah and
you're not good at it you get so far
left in the dust name that's very true
that's why it don't every tickets also
good luck if you're like oh damn I'm
gonna start podcast now boom yeah it's
gonna be tough yeah it is tough because
you're competing with entrenched well
it's not like it is even three years ago
even two years ago right [__] is moving
quick
I just latched on to a young man with a
lot of energy I just I just had a
conversation with these guys you know I
just have to say this before you go on
when I first started doing a podcast
with you and I just saw something in you
obviously yeah like not just funny but I
just saw hustle and that's business
savvy and and we were friends actually
no I did we're buddies
I wasn't that you were like oh I'm gonna
make sure I never expected any money I
know I just like never do we just were
doing this but but uh but I will say
that I had a lot of people telling me
dude what are you doing podcasts for
you're wasting your [__] time you got
to start acting and stuff the best thing
I ever did was this for my career so
hands down I can't tell you - yeah yeah
I'm gonna do man certain things I go out
to her I'm like I don't carefully I get
this or not I guess I'll just do my show
and who are you get this off from like
well I make this much doing this though
somehow you know it's just it's glorious
I'm so thankful but I was having a
conversation with some business peeps
that I'm connected with and they were
like man we'd love for you to sit down
have a conversation with Amber Rose
because she was to speak following
she's great on a mic and she just didn't
take podcast serious I know she could be
so good at that
she's so brilliant she studied well bird
amber / Rosie how much you be sir
there's a come on what the body yes and
she had her own show on e and she's good
she's good she's amazing and so you know
she's kind of the limelight right now
and yes she saw it she was Kanye's girls
she was whisk ELISA girl baby mama and
they were like we'd love for you to sit
down just talk to her about the the pros
of doing a podcast cuz they look at it
almost a negative light I'm like well I
could destroy all her roadblocks or
mental roadblocks on podcasting and
literally one lunch it was look real
real big hmm they're not real they look
real big she's a sec she's one of
George's yeah start off as a stripper
just like cardi B mm-hmm I'm a fan well
people like that find their way through
when they find their way through they've
got something it's not just cuz they're
hot know she could kill it in the right
platform everything that should kill it
right all right Jim what comments you
got shot to Amber Rose action sense by
the way Ronda Rousey there was talk that
she might join the W E and now it's
official she signed a full-time contract
with him and I guess she was in
yesterday's Royal Rumble she did finish
Beale there cool good for her man I mean
listen it's tough enough I think this is
smarter for her than do movies I agree
I think her put all her eggs in the
basket of entertainment like Gina Carano
did that Gina is doing great but I think
that's such a more difficult road for
her talent wise I think dub dubby makes
perfect sense she's always been in WBE
it's a huge following she has potential
be maybe the biggest WB diva ever I
think if that's what they call them
still but as far as female girls no joke
and also you know you don't get punched
in the face it don't now when I input
that when I say this and I don't know
what training she's done I have no idea
try though that's a beast
alright and then the one thing that's a
little alarming there is what it says
signs on this full-time
now she going on the road 300 days a
year and she's taking those Falls and
she's
so goldberg about this dr. steve austin
i have a lot of friends who are in it
now i'm actually giving it more into it
it's a monster it's a monster so clean
so in and i'll say this in the same
conversation I have with a lot of
athletes once you're all would you stand
up now that's fine if that's what you
want to do why are you doing it though
because if you if you see people you
know I'm doing it because I want to make
money I don't know why Ron does do it if
it's because if wrestling's our passion
then you're gonna make it if stand-ups
your passion then you're gonna make it
if it is not it's the same as the thing
that got you in fighting if it is not
your passion it's nighttime Tony it's
not for the hustle so insane and the
competition is so insane you're gonna
get burnt out you're never gonna make is
gonna be a bad choice so I think with
this guys why am I doing this do you
think that she's for money and notoriety
probably I can amazing there's a small
tug to go back to MMA and prove herself
no no yeah I think the game's evolved so
much and when you're especially when
you're doing WIB yeah you remember you
know Brock Lesnar is such a physical
freakin such a big guy but when he met
someone who with a skill real skill he's
in a lot of trouble a lot of trouble now
with Ronda the game's evolved so much
Amanda noonas he's getting better she's
in there she gonna be a man in is she me
Holly Holm right now she a fight cyborg
you want you on do a super focus cyborg
so at her level you're gonna come back
we can't give you a the number 9 the
number not 10 the number 11 girl yeah
it's gonna have to be a super fight and
you'll find a monster now you're gonna
find a monster but you've been you've
lacked better words you've been faking
them till you can't it doesn't it's not
gonna work now doesn't translate no
ingredients up for another knockout and
ruin and knocked you down
lowered when we thought you wouldn't
everyone's high I hope she sticks I hope
she's the biggest thing in WWE ball plan
I hope it's her calling and I hope she
finds her happiness there man that'd be
really cool yeah awesome what else you
got this one I don't know how much of a
current event is but that guy a little
Aussie vert I went hard on this manager
interview I went really hard and before
you get into it little Aussie vert which
when I say that makes me feel old so you
must feel like Jesus Christ and I say
that so little Aussie
in the interview yes he's you know I
don't even know his hit I can tell you a
song let some old it makes me feel but
he came dressed like like a high school
when I was kid that when in high school
was like a skater like the big chinko
jeans and the chains hanging off and the
vans and that you know he's very emo ish
like this weird new culture of rap
whatever what is the new culture of rap
is it becoming more slacker kind of like
the white kids or what is I like Moses
Malone little Uzi little symbol oh yeah
but they tap their faces that's the
biggest thing with picture a little
variable a picture you see verb for very
but so time does the interview on red
carpet and Giuliani goes what how you
doing what they like to be it's the
Grammys it's the biggest thing you can
do it for your musical artists and he
goes this is my life same thing as
always and she is she was okay well I
work nice-looking kid yeah for sure he's
never gonna commit suicide so he he's
just very emo ish and she goes what are
you gonna do if you win tonight he goes
let me say man I'll probably wake up a
pop-tarts might go shopping she's like
it's a big night for you guys yeah I
don't know what's going on there he's
just uh he's an artist man is he and so
I said on ear I went I went did he just
robbed a hot topic yeah I said it looks
like just robbed a hot topic which is on
whatever I should have said that but
yeah I thought it's a shitty interview
different was like it's yeah the one
thing I can't get down with you know I
can't get down with the fake stuff oh my
god little boozy how how fun was that
that was terrible and [__] you man yes I
was awful don't come don't come
that's your vibe but also you drew what
you would people want to go I'm the
anthem like twenty one pilots last year
they were the anti man I'm not gonna
dress up [__] this award one show up in
our boxer shorts though here's the thing
that is a state that is a style what
you're doing is if fashion style what
you're doing that's a type of peacock
costume that's a that's an action cause
it's called that's an attitude it's
called affectation it's like I told us
to wrote down what your fanny pack is
eight is a form of peacocking yeah even
though I get it you think it's nerdy
that and I know you're not the most
rational guy what you
is a fashion statement you're actually
being fast when we were that fanny-pack
what do you like you're not the nerd
look is a look there's a no there's a
Greek and ancient Greek philosopher and
the the ingredients in Greece of course
people were always trying to find the
truth and in walks a group of people who
are there they're essentially dressed in
the finest of clothing and they were
there's part of this this cult that
believed in you know you know expressing
the senses like eating really good food
good sex and there and beauty and
they're all about me yes yeah so they're
all dress like the high fashion and the
guy goes like this the guy goes the
great philosopher okay maybe the Seneca
goes a fact ation as in you weren't you
know you were in a costume like you're
saying and then another group comes in
these these kids were facing they wanted
to they're in stood in the afterlife and
totally negating any kind of material
wealth and they showed up in rags they
were skinny they hadn't eaten and he
goes more effect that being the anti
like that so blame the designer all that
stuff the main strength so Lane so we're
gonna wear all black okay is this stop
either way you're you're all in the same
boat which you guys don't get you're all
going to the same destination you're all
making a statement
yeah it's so you will get a lot of
people have been through this like these
these the problem of expressing your
individuality has been around forever
but if you actually look at a lot of the
people that made a huge difference like
there did and I'm not saying all of this
but like there are artists that just
show up and that's not how they
expressions they do it through their
work they do it through I'm not saying a
lot but like like artists yeah right it
could tomp a volleyball thank gosh I've
come to the conclusion I used to make
fun of fashion I've come to the
conclusion as I was sat with it for a
long time which is that I have a great
deal of respect for it because it's like
anything else a form of artistic
expression yeah it creates a lot of
color and value for all of us around
like when we I don't want to live in a
world where ever as we're in the same
[__] no and you don't realize how much
creativity goes in not only how much
creativity goes into craftsmanship
craftsmanship
but also how our next people like me I'm
not a fashion guy but look at my shoes
suddenly I'm wearing something I like
this and we like my nephew's right
they're not into clothing until I bought
them really expensive shirts from James
purse say we will about chance / - ease
concert if they never stop wearing those
shirts when you wear something cool
you're gonna you're gonna notice the
difference though you should believe you
should leave my country for those shows
these huge all these are great man like
a boxing Gucci shoes get out of here but
whatever don't my style I thought is so
funny like so on the e panel that Jason
he's the stars
I mean mary j blige everybody always
does everyone and I made some comments
it just gives Gucci sells it doesn't you
have to wear it and we get off he goes
what is your deal man here's what you're
more in the fashion we are up here what
is your how do you know so much that I
go I'm just always into it band and he
goes here straight Malan I do I'm so
straight to playing funny if you could
hear my thoughts with going on the car
through freak you're straight I did yeah
I'm just super into it man I don't know
why the I was a kid like my brothers
someone at when the live circus what
Brenda's always been into fashion jegos
always and J tells a story in fourth
grade my mom let me go the store and
dress myself and I got this silk green
shirt the silk dark green shirt and then
I got this that like how they call a
cowboy tie it had like a dead skeleton
with leather things hanging off I put
that on with jeans on and then put on
boots
terrible terrible but you wanted to make
you loved it yeah RuPaul I tweeted at an
interview with RuPaul yeah a really good
interview because the woman is like this
really liberal kind of woman is trying
to get him to get did but did do drag
queens that have to do Queens have to
wear heels I feel like we should free
them from the tyranny of heels she's
part of this whole thing and RuPaul goes
RuPaul goes heels flats flats flats are
for quitters oh and by the way no not
everybody gets to make it on my show
because you know what life isn't fair
and if you want it you got a
work for it and be good I don't work his
hands right and she he is right no I
work with RuPaul back in the deck I tell
you attention to I think sometimes and
it's like a lot of my fallings bros
right so when I post stuff about fashion
and beyond it's always it's roasted but
it's it's just the the culture around
it's so weird to me because also
fashioned isn't about gucci or being
real it doesn't have to be really
expensive you can go to American Eagle
you could go to H&M and you I mean can I
don't be with dressing you know some
people know how together you have to be
into it yes it's not about expensive
stuff some people matter if some people
not have put it together yeah people are
minimalist and they can push it and
you're like how do you know that that
goes with that yeah you know yep it's
very interesting what else you get you
also that thing with love boozy so his
songs that one song goes all my friends
are dead
you know that song no I don't why tell
my friends did you know that song MJ
he's been through some [__] yeah I think
yeah yeah he's a super artist he's emo
you know up to his defense what everyone
on the panel I was with last night who
know him goes he's the nicest guy ever
good they might don't go too hard on him
cuz when I saw that everyone went I'm
telling you if he comes here and does
that I'm not gonna be friendly he's
actually really nice he's just you might
be socially awkward around people yeah
you know this song all my friend this is
he one of songs of yours I know I
thought it was little Wayne I know when
I first heard I might go a little Wayne
sounds like Lil Wayne now it's very
computerized
[Music]
well I feel like you should be dancing
slower no don't spread that ration of it
you've heard this song though right I
know the song well you haven't heard
this gin no honestly I am old because
they all sound
yeah whatever heard this song holy [__]
alright get it off please Danny make it
go away so she said she said I mean
saying yeah I might blow my brain out
Danny numb the pain yeah please Danny
make it go away
Jesus Christ going through some hard
stuff obviously no [__] he needs a hug
little Aussie needs a hug usually when
people tattoo their face like that
there's that's the thing now though it's
it's crazy it's everywhere that little
pump would just died tattooed face yeah
and you know all the thing that kids are
into now and again when I talk to these
kids it's all Danny's and pills and
[__] tied things I'm amazing yeah
they're eating time like I'm amazed at
how many people do like human beings
have always always tried to get out of
their state right they've always wanted
to get into another state it goes back
so far human beings have always
experimental implants drugs capping
everything drugs a deafening part of
being human experiences to kind of get
out of your sober state the Indians did
some [__] aside the peyote the losing
and and what's fascinating is that it's
no different now but I feel like there's
a spiritual malaise I think that a huge
part of it maybe I'm an old guy talking
but I think that there I feels like two
things are going on one is people feel
like they're completely powerless to
control anything around them because of
the the world that's so big and then
someone stays machine and also I think
people are very confused on purpose I
don't think there's I think a lot of
people are miss
purpose I greet here's the other thing
is now social media before if I was just
a kid from Denver
I saw what everyone had going on around
me in Denver well now again social media
I see what Billy in Florida is doing I'm
like oh my god you can hire your sites
but now no no I can't Peter myself but I
can see what Kylie Jenner looks like
when she wakes up in the one who soar
bed her clothes her cars so now yours
you're looking at that going well [__] I
have this man now why suicide so high
right now
when did it'd be cool to kill yourself
what in the [__] are we do I think it's
a spiritual malaise I think it's like
when you feel like nothing you do
matters when you feel like nothing you
do can contribute to anything when you
feel like you don't matter like your
existence doesn't matter in a world is
great you're agreeing with everything
one piece of your and and that there
used to be I think a way out of that
which was there is a way to stop you
there is a way out but I think because
we gravitate towards negativity but just
as much negativity that there's on
social media there's much more positive
yeah but we're brains are we gravitate
towards the negativity and negativity
they want to huddle together negativity
they want the club together if you look
at if someone posted a negative post
there's gonna be a bunch more them but
someone's waiting for them because they
want to be part of that Club
because there's something going on in
their life but again this this is just
if I want to find activity I can go down
a whole horrible wrap around your neck
or I used to avoid all of it and I can
find positivity put your phone down you
put your phone down but if let's say
you're a young kid and you're gonna be
on your phone you find more positive
than a gas you're sure that's true and
you have to yeah man it's a really
interesting phenomenon just because look
at all the people that you look up to
would include myself if I follow you I'd
be you the friend I look up to you
no one's posting negative [__] don't I
don't see any network no they're doing
work to set an example send in the pace
they're carrying that pathan going to
come on come [__] grab it I watched I
was in so I don't know why you'd follow
anyone who's not setting that that mold
is setting that paint I thought about
this because I was at there's a really
good restaurant Columbus called North
Star and it's like all farm-to-table and
they they it's all local stuff
and I was looking at this and we know
there's a lot of stuff in the news about
equal pay and women and women
empowerment and racism and and I was
watching this and this is in Columbus
Ohio and there were so many different
types of people who were working there
black white Hispanic Asian I mean all
different kinds and there were men and
they were women and they were just
working and I was watching them and they
were it was such a well-oiled machine
this restaurant and it was such an
incredible example of cooperation nobody
was trying to have power over anybody
else you know what they were trying to
do get the best-tasting food to
customers they could and they required
this incredible team effort and I
thought to myself if you got a lot of
rice was great about this is what's
great about like actual businesses that
work with nobody here is talking about
that they're just enjoying there's a
motor buses that work like that don't
correct way my think a lot of people
that are driving the narratives actually
don't work they're busy talking and
writing and they're not doing yeah and
when you do it changes but also the
people which is the majority who operate
like that don't have time to jump you
don't have time like why they don't have
time well of course we have a sexual
conduct policy here what ya do that yeah
we're busy making the best guys only
care exactly exactly yeah and that's
exactly right of the pot you know woman
who is running it the guy that got only
here from the from the I think it's you
here from the victims which they should
have a voice that's great yeah and then
you hear from the other people who just
want this again negativity you know it
[__] it just builds man it's everyone
can jump in it alone mentality gets
vicious Twitter I've been on Twitter
lately just a little bit I peek at
what's really going on in terms of like
in your comments no not my comments on
like these these fights I'll just read
some the new somebody's in trouble or
whatever and the amount of venom that
goes back and forth on Twitter the
negative [__] if you can get caught in
that rabbit hole Wow it's very strange a
to the on Instagram or to mainly
Instagram it'll be some just horrible
she'll make you know you can disagree
without insulting that man yeah
it shows your level of intelligence when
you're your first missile launch is
reply back is negative and super mean
yes like it it just shows a stupid yard
yeah it's such a
bummer yep if you go down that rabbit
hole by meow like oh my god people are
so [__] stupid sometimes
it's the negativeness doesn't know we
and as far as men and women you by the
way if women rule the world women are
really easy on each other you ever knows
how nice they are to each other
oh don't don't join us that's the a
don't click oh my god and especially
young beautiful women they're gonna have
a great time in a woman run oh no pretty
girls oh you know how nice other women
are to the really pretty girl female
comic tells because they're so
supportive of each other last all cops
female comics show you went to we have
to all realize we're human beings with
tendencies it ain't gonna change with
one gender over the other it's it's it
you know yeah treated like individual
individual hello loses [__] is sad
though
alright Chuck Liddell he's gonna be on
this season's Big Brother sure is going
on yeah oh do she shut up Chuck Liddell
you see him wearing the fire and the kid
never never summer t on his reality show
no YouTube red yeah I posted it I had to
sign off on it just like is a cool run
the endless timer to end the summer to
yeah which we're gonna we're actually
I'm stalking roots a fight we're gonna
rerelease and then we Shan we're making
a we're doing a cloud but chin and Brian
fight shirt oh great yeah great alright
we gotta do yeah so what's it say here I
didn't know the show still going on so
it's like a reality but it's it's more
of a celebrity
Brother house for the first time for a
real house Billy Hills Brandi Glanville
apprentice villain Oh Omar she worked
for Trump she got fired or she she quit
she quest she quit American Pie actress
Shannon Elizabeth never mad at her
Sugar Ray frontman mark McGrath who's on
this shows brilliant he's hilarious
TV personally Ross Matthews he's funny
you know him from Jay Leno the super
high-pitched
man that likes boys not I'm sorry not
like boys but doesn't and then Oh Metta
World Peace Cosby Show alum Kesha Knight
Big Time Rush big times Big Time Rush's
james maslow
miss Colombia all right here spray star
and formula city light heavyweight
champion Chuck Liddell damn I'm kind of
into it I'll watch that [__]
what's he doing there they use on dance
with the Stars I think I voted off first
though you think I'm stiff boy he's dead
he's stiff
I feel like you put me on this arm do
all right yeah you you I think you would
yeah you're stiff though man I mean I
think we got voted off first
you know who else would not do well on
Dancing with the Stars Joe Rogan no
dancer it's flexible never seen him
dance never seen him even make one move
it you know there soon never seen him do
that even know what else you guys doing
oh my god you know I've cut into that
with that castle yeah sure what is Big
Brother you just watch they just look at
the house right it's a reality show they
live in a house it's like the real world
but grown folks yeah and it's just
literally just watching them what they
do there's nothing really special
applying except for one
once in a while they do game I got a
feeling it's just boy you're probably
starting to freak out on somebody in
fact I bet on a news truck freak out on
Metta World Peace I bet metal World
Peace and Chuck Liddell in a fist fight
Oh No doesn't matter beat him no
questions although that is [__] huge
you're assuming that fight too when he's
on the Pacers I make my kids saw I know
it will use the front-runner that I saw
him fight the fan I think yeah yeah a
fan went that fan goes oh wait a minute
pieces
if Metta trained Chuck's gonna have his
hands full with me Chuck trucks a holder
would touch them it was his living for a
long time yeah chuckle take it down what
else you got gin I'm kind of excited for
that show I don't watch big brother his
Mehta retired yeah Elon Musk
he made a flamethrower not too long ago
as a goof I know and it ended up he said
if everyone buys like I think 50,000
hats of his new company boring then he
would make flamethrowers available to
the public to sell why would we want to
flame though exactly why would anyone
want is there something happening that I
don't know yeah well azam be a POC this
happens you'll be glad you bought a
flamethrower works against hordes of the
undead or your money back because there
was it the one before that was a
contrary to what people think I'm not
there
that I'm secretly creating a zombie
apocalypse to generate demand for
flamethrowers is completely false I love
it it's already made almost or over four
million dollars
hey how about it would you need millions
of he's actually really funny just
really you need millions of zombies for
so called apocalypse anyways where would
I even get a factory big enough to make
so many kind of funny real personalities
this is his the do they show the
flamethrower I'll find it for you
he's amazing well you know it's 28% of
us 68 billion outcomes no six are fifty
billion dollar company 650b how much way
is that six I'm fifty billion give me
thirty percent go back again I don't
think it was six fifty sixty eight dope
seeks hundred fifty billion guys I see
it again that's a lot of money I have to
see it again
yeah the goal is the video you're
playing okay I'll see you yes play that
and then it's you fast-forward and it
was on when the fast-forward part it's
not playing out in throwers I don't want
people having flamethrowers oh my god
imagine Kelly Carly has a flamethrower
the flattop throw the company who is he
dating
Oh Johnny Depp's girl Justin earns by
70% 6r 50 billion Brian
[Music]
so what's 28% of six-armed 50 billion
Jen I can't put on my calculator well
it's it's the one-third basically well
all you do use worth one hundred eighty
four billion dollars oh my god
what do you do I mean well we always
talk about that how long is it a billion
seconds you know that's 133 years do you
start with that there's 150 for it says
you've got 154 of those does do you do
Wow you just try to make the world a
better place um yeah give it to you like
you you build your basically your spark
the Ironman spark house and then you
just kind of you know you out have it no
it's gonna mean I thought of as ooh look
at that that's a flame that's his
flamethrower huh I don't think that's
first I don't like who that cool also
should people have oh here it is let me
see it I'm not back out it hurt to get
hit with that [__] thing yeah dad
also what am I getting ready for a
running man what they used to use shut
or else worth taking running man oh my
god that would be terrifying the
cameraman was like um it's alongside a
boring company product line so a real
flames are shoots for yeah and it shoots
you ever seen the movie running man
that's the only time you'd need it a
channel 2 million yeah I think it set
you on fire it senses I'd be the fat guy
with the Christmas lights all over yeah
the flamethrower that's a hell of a way
to die flamethrower yeah and people have
and it's not good what else gets in so
it just came out he already sold over
like seven thousand and you already made
over four million dollars doing chores
what who's buying that for what people
wild are useful a burger come 500 bucks
this is left on he's just gonna shoot
you with your stupid flamethrower yeah
this is cool to have now
everyone had a flamethrower would make
more sense yeah but if I'll stick with
the burgers like what all right bro yeah
stick with my gun also I'm gonna shoot
that gas tank when we have it yeah yes
and kill everybody all right what else
you got this is what I was reading
earlier that a patient in India got
sucked into an MRI machine and died they
don't have vacuum yeah these are all
hands they're magnet right and I guess
he was carrying an oxygen tank that the
doctor told his staffer like you know
take care of this guy and that staffer
told him can you carry that into the
room for some reason heavy I'm not sure
so it was so and he was like hey what do
you do here yes that's exactly what
happened that's what they're saying
happen but it's so complete broken his
neck but when he was like yeah you just
go into the machine yeah so in staffer
said it was off he was are you sure and
we walked in and apparently he was still
holding tightly to it it's got sucked in
the machine and then I guess the mr. I'm
sorry the the thing burst and he had too
much oxygen at one time oh my so that
killed him instantly
oh so he didn't get like hit something
with his head the machine went yeah you
got sucked in with it sucked into the
machine but then that the canister hit
the machine burst he had too much oxygen
come into the face and he killed him so
these are just super powerful magnets
and you know hell yeah you know and also
you don't do too many of my eyes a lot
of athletes do it so a ton of radiation
radiation residence no radiation from
what I hear I don't think guys who have
too much they always tell you not to get
too many of em I don't think MRIs have
radiation it's magnetic resonance
imaging so no I know that but this comes
to ask and pray so do Google MRI and
radiation there you go
because that's why pregnant that's why
pregnant girls non-invasive imaging
Texas three-dimensional detailed
automatically images without the use of
damaging radiation yeah doesn't use
radiation no one-of-a-kind specialized
to Mars that's why so it's magnetic
resonance imaging it actually doesn't
create it so there is there's no
negative side effects because MRIs do
not use x-rays or other radiation so
just you just gotta be worried about the
x-rays then right no yeah actually yeah
yeah really just so close to your face
your brain yeah that's sucked from that
guy go get on my eyes like it's all good
what else get yeah
Air Force one they're replacing the
refrigerators and apparently cost twenty
four million dollars ok refrigerators
are they missing very special
refrigerators that were their old now
they they want to make sure that they
last for a long time for a future
presidents can refrigerators they are ok
kind of like the right way and the left
wing the right wings like small
government unless it comes to buying a
[__] the five aircraft carriers for
nine point four billion dollars each but
no spending all right guys there's a
small government and the but the
refrigerators of twenty four million
dollars you know you know who got the
biggest supply at the Grammys you know
wait hold can I guess was it a woman or
a man it's a woman okay who got the
largest applause I for Clinton
yes yeah and you know what they were
doing liberal crowd they were doing yeah
reading trucks yeah yeah yeah cardi B
goes each cheeseburgers goes I'm not
reading this [__] he really got that
she's no [__] so hilarious
just having the artist read it and then
he was from New York she's got that [__]
on Bronx yeah and then she's Puerto
Rican but then there's one where it's
reading and you see a blonde like hair
sticking out and it's Hillary is a whole
crowd yeah
did you see car to be in person yes I
saw her next to Bruno Mars in it and
Bruno Mars is actually quite a bit
taller than her yeah he had put heels on
like your face he'll she's about five -
okay so she's real small to her sister
Hennessy is gorgeous too
and that whole family is just a banger
yes she's got she's Kirby trying to be
I've never really bring her up for a
second
I'm see your sister and I see he really
like that huh get a sister yeah gorgeous
man both of them so broke you know Cody
that's her sister Hennessey you know
cardi B's man cheated on her and then
her man got a tattoo on his neck to make
up for it and a $500,000 diamond ring
and a $500,000 diamond wow that's
expensive click on this one Jim what's
going on here what's going on that with
that one oh that's weird
twerking her sister's just working on a
strange make sure for something for I
thought she was doing on that screen
behind her that PlayStation 1 yeah I
think it's PlayStation that said that
that sounds time yeah you zoom in on
that I just make sure yeah look closer
there we go they're gorgeous girls
though man yeah I don't know you're
talking about I'm just looking at the
PlayStation all right what else yeah Jen
um how about this
this is mainstream news for some reason
Jen Selter she's enormous on Instagram
she got kicked off of an American
Airlines flight because she stood up
wait hon she's the one that called out
Louie CK right that right or know that
different Jen Jen Selter is she's not a
convenient she's a fitness she calls
herself a fitness model but she's just
known for their ass well you're up
bring her up bring her up chin
apparently the other the other people on
the flight came to her defense because
this guy was being mean to her it seemed
like they're both kind of being
obnoxious with each other
she's got mrs. Hill roblems on the eyes
she's super famous for her but well keep
going keep going
all right all right yeah it's cool
oh yeah she just cool that's right
before nothing crazy she's not as so
many followers 13 million or 11 million
yeah well I'll fill your my face yeah
any of those are BOTS and real oh is
that all
kidding me ha ha plot thickens getting
even kardashian when they when they did
hers you know it not be BOTS it could be
her publicist you know she lost like six
billion I love and I said don't worry
senator do you think what other people
think of you meanwhile she's just always
showing her ass like yeah I love that
yeah I love that it's just about inner
beauty but you spent so much time in
your outer shell what do you mean like
your businesses your inner your outer
shell what the she's cool so much that
groundbreaking I don't I don't know best
friend workout buddy photographer
partner in crime nobody loves you more
than me I'm so lucky to call you my big
sister thank you for always being there
for me you are the other half I don't
know what to do without you I love you
my little peanut and every day just this
general stuff it's so I'll tell you this
too anytime see girls and thongs on a
yacht yeah I'm gonna think about what
after that pictures old friend and are
you saying that yeah boy I would agree
with you as if I was older and single
and I owned a boat you best believe me
going needle up in here oh no I can't
believe you send that out loud well not
saying if I was older man no and and I
have a timeshare on the side going anal
up in here well look at him I know dude
this Oh guess what this boat ain't
floating itself
enjoy the crab and then get on the
nerves that's the song you sing it so I
try yeah get on me nerds you rub my back
while she sucks there's not you know
like that this is if I was a rich yacht
okay so you're playing a wrist shot on
it you would never do that but you don't
approve no I don't approve that's no
that's whatever you started to get love
flat your fame to get laid wrong with
you don't use your power you mean one
more picture Jim Canton bring up one
more picture brother oh it's a vision
got a small waist and she's eating
something like a marshmallow
she's so
yeah I mean she's not vain she's easy on
the eyes for sure it's no family going
on there I would not kick her out of my
bed freaking Korean spareribs let's just
say that chip yeah sticky ribs you don't
want those in your bed I let her eat
those in my bed question would the
sticky ribs you better be a down [__]
one let you eat stinky red baby damage I
would let her eat sticky ribs in my bed
or even chips and guacamole that also
gets go back to the other one because I
have an outfit just like that uh-huh
once again go ahead back to that once
again when you see these pigs and their
swans in the back and it's a giant
mansion as soon as they get done taking
the pigs it's double penetration open
here little eggs
oh well dizzy i rhyming alright we
assume DP yeah we did we assume do you
like hey bro if I'm single I'm 55 you
ain't taking pictures hanging out my
crib just for the [__] of it you know
those swans in the back they seen some
[__] I don't want to just look and not
touch if you know what I'm saying little
swans
I might miss some bust on the Swan it's
getting it ugly up in here so I can
count the number of times I've been to a
strip club in the past 20 years I don't
get down strip clubs alright moving on
by one more chip Oh would you say she
was last I went to strip club yesterday
and this morning is genuinely good
busting your pants at the strip club on
accident well are you a connoisseur of
strip club you can tell I've been there
uh what's funny is I met Chuck Liddell
like years ago before it's 5:02 toe
that's part of the last time I went at
the strip club in Vegas or the fighter
after before the fight and make sense
all right that was anywhere that's how
long he's in Christ
utterly that when you got Itoh to the
first one oh wow a long time ago that's
Lester in a strip club I've been there
about three times four especially for a
bachelor party stuff that's it but you
you all just like I don't know let's
take your paycheck and stroll in there
every surpri day or so I myself know I
went in there a long one time driving
back
did you really long ago I was like it
was like 15 years ago maybe maybe maybe
12 years ago maybe last month I caramel
by the way I'm driving back
mr. Philip and I just was like I had
nothing to do I'm gonna go in there I go
in there and guess what I see a girl
from my acting class I was so [__]
embarrassment so is she oh she dances
she wasn't that fun she was dancing why
would you be embarrassed be cool you
know sullen I know she was like you're
in here alone I was like oh my buddy
searched for a part I think I said that
she goes yeah right and I was like all
right was a terrible library right how
much for a dance however good like the
food at sapphires is delicious
they have sushi rolls there though but
hey yeah stop it although I'm not eating
the food West Palm Beach
Rachel's which I'm gonna go to Rachel's
at West Palm Beach I have it on good
authority is a five-star steak
restaurant and you go there yup and
you'll see some Justin or March 24th -
son oh man you know me oh I'm there's -
sometime in March really yeah same time
as much I don't know I can't remember
what you said yeah what else you got amp
up all Beach Orlando that's my flow
that's a good that's a good run tampon
Orlando does that I lasted last one is
this app called Strava as is crazy I'm
sorry this right yeah this is like in
November they started the the company
started posting global heat maps of
where their app is being used that and a
kid from Australia a student Australia
thought saw like the heat maps in
certain areas in Syria and other places
where US forces are at like their bases
are at and they could actually track
because these the soldiers put you know
they using the app so they want to track
how they're doing their stuff so they
could find out where they're running
what time where they're at exactly so
yeah about Intel that they're getting
from just this app Wow yeah so what we
can do not use the Fitbit anymore just
turn off those yeah it's something you
called Strava same kind of oh wow see
right there holy [__] the ice is like
hello yeah wow I never when I'm doing
missions I was for my cell ever I always
put on airplane mode and
go to work I stay off social media
there's no selfies with the king of
selfies [__] selfies up in here not
walking around my Fitbit I mean the
homies ride a train on each other we
celebrate huh what because we're a group
of aggressive gays aggressive gays we're
a group of great wealth get me back guys
great to be back everybody beware you
got this week mad you ass buddy come on
road noise the CCM bras and come out and
see me at the brand improv the weekend
after February 8th 9th and 10th Preah
improv I'm bringing some serious heat
new baya Brennan what February 28th I'm
showcasing at the Melrose improv
February 20th doing an hour comedy for
certain people in the end does it rhyme
with bet flicks it's gonna be some
people does it rhyme with Mille at MIT
it's gonna be some people brother do the
run with bobbidi dental does it rhyme
with boat I'm puffin he dental yeah and
bow time it's got some people coming
love it February 28th so get your
tickets um this week Jesus Christ figure
out what date is Wednesday night Denver
Comedy Works downtown there are 50
tickets left of that [__] sells out
Thursday night is sold out Friday and
Saturday st. Louis helium I'm coming
like Nellie st. Louis gets tickets st.
Louis I'm comin
what's up and then Vancouver guess what
Frankie lives back on what Brad's not
going to Saturday be going to Saudi
Arabia it's been postponed which usually
means it's never going to happen
happening yep it's right for the best
cuz you're gonna get murdered up I was
looking so that plane ride yeah not
happening bro
anyways fine kid will be live March 2nd
in Vancouver my show March 1st is sold
out fine kid army let's do this
Vancouver theater Bryan count myself get
your tickets tea fat Kate calm and also
we just added Orlando to my Florida tour
so I go Tampa Palm Beach Orlando end of
March get tickets now chief at kake.com
this is a farm kid route